♪
♪ OH ♪
>> Jesse: BAD NEWS, AMERICA.
ACCORDING TO TOP DEMOCRATS,
DEMOCRACY IS GOING TO DIE
TOMORROW IN THE LAST FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION EVER.
>> ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTIONS OF OUR LIFETIME.
IT'S GOING TO SHAPE THE OUTCOME
IS GOING TO SHAPE OUR COUNTRY
FOR DECADES TO COME, AND THE
POWER TO SHAPE THAT OUTCOME IS
IN YOUR HANDS.
>> WHEN TRUE DEMOCRACY GOES
AWAY, PEOPLE GET HURT.
IT HAS REAL CONSEQUENCES.
THIS IS NOT AN ABSTRACTION.
GOVERNMENTS START TELLING YOU
WHAT BOOKS YOU CAN READ AND
WHICH ONES YOU CAN'T.
DISSIDENTS START GETTING LOCKED
UP.
REPORTERS START GETTING LOCKED
UP IF THEY'RE NOT TOWING THE
PARTY LINE.
CORRUPTION REIGNS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Jesse: AMERICA'S 200-YEAR-OLD
DEMOCRACY IS GOING TO DIE IF
REPUBLICANS WIN.
THE SAME COUNTRY THAT SURVIVED A
CIVIL WAR, GREAT DEPRESSION, TWO
WORLD WARS AND WILL SMITH'S
OSCAR SLAP.
BEST PART IS THE WAY IT'S GOING
TO END IS BY PEOPLE VOTING.
IF THAT'S NOT DIRE ENOUGH, THIRD
MOST POWERFUL DEMOCRAT IN THE
HOUSE DOUBLED DOWN IN HIS
COMPARISON OF THE REPUBLICANS TO
HITLER.
>> DEMOCRACY WILL BE ENDED.
THE WORLD WILL CONTINUE TO
EXIST.
THE WORLD WAS HERE BEFORE
HITLER.
THE WORLD WAS HERE AFTER HITLER.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SAYING.
NO, THE WORLD WILL NOT END.
THE KIND OF WORLD WE HAVE.
THE KIND OF COUNTRY THAT WE
HAVE.
WE'VE GOT TO DECIDE HOW DO WE
WANT TO EXIST IN THIS WORLD?
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Jesse: IF YOU THOUGHT THAT
WAS RIDICULOUS, HOLLYWOOD LIBES
LIKE ROB REINER THINKS
REPUBLICANS WILL LITERALLY START
KILLING PEOPLE.
>> OTHER SIDE REALITY DOESN'T
MEAN ANYTHING.
THEY'RE ONLY INTERESTED IN
POWER.
AND THEY ARE ONLY INTERESTED IN
-- AND THEY'LL DO ANYTHING TO
GET THE POWER.
THEY'RE WILLING TO KILL.
LITERALLY KILL TO GET THE POWER.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THEM.
THE ONLY THING WE CAN DO IS TRY
TO HOLD ON TO THE HOUSE, ADD A
COUPLE OF SENATE SEATS.
IT WILL BE VERY HARD.
IF WE DON'T DO THAT, THIS MIGHT
BE THE LAST ELECTION WE HAVE IN
A DEMOCRATIC DEMOCRACY -- IN A
DEMOCRACY.
>> Jesse: SO GREG GUTFELD, IF
DEMOCRACY IS GOING TO DIE ON
WEDNESDAY, SHOULD YOU BE WEARING
A HAWAIIAN SHIRT ON MONDAY?
>> Greg: IT'S WEIRD BEING CALLED
HITLER BY SOMEBODY WHO LOOKS
LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO A
PRESENTATION FOR A TIME SHARE.
IT'S SOMETHING ELSE.
BUT I DON'T KNOW, DOES IT MATTER
IF THE PERSON CALLING YOU HITLER
OR SAYING YOU'RE LIKE A NAZI
DOESN'T MEAN IT?
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING.
I GO BACK TO THE WHOLE THING
WHEN KAMALA HARRIS BASICALLY
CALLED BIDEN A RACIST.
AFTERWARDS WHEN THEY ASKED HER
ABOUT IT, SHE'S LIKE IT'S JUST A
DEBATE.
SHE BEGAN LAUGHING.
I'M GOING OK, IS THAT WORSE?
I MEAN, YOU'RE STILL CALLING
SOMEBODY A BIGOT OR YOU'RE STILL
CALLING SOMEBODY A RACIST.
THEY THINK THE DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION, WE FORGET ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
BUT I THINK WE HIT THE WALL.
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE.
I REALLY THINK WE'VE HIT THE
WALL.
WHAT ELSE ARE YOU GOING TO CALL
US BEYOND NAZI?
IN 10 YEARS, NAZI IS GOING TO BE
MILD.
IT'S LIKE THAT'S INSULTING TO
HITLER.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> Greg: THAT'S HOW IT'S GOING.
IT'S CRAZY!
>> Jesse: ARE WE GOING TO PLAY
THIS TAPE OF ROB REINER SAYING
THE REPUBLICANS ARE LITERALLY
GOING TO KILL PEOPLE AND TURN
INTO NAZI GERMANY?
I THINK WE'LL HEAR A LOT OF THAT
FOOTAGE FOR ABOUT THE NEXT YEAR.
>> Dana: YOU WANT TO WATCH IT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN?
REMEMBER THE STATISTICS THAT
JUDGE JEANINE POINTED OUT IN THE
A BLOCK, 60% OF PEOPLE ARE
ASKING FOR DRASTIC CHANGE.
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRACY IS ALL
ABOUT.
YOU BROUGHT UP THE POINT THAT
DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT REPRESENTING
THE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING WE'D LIKE SOME
CHANGE.
THE OTHER THING IS LET'S GET
SOME PERSPECTIVE ON HISTORY.
THE WHITE HOUSE KNEW ON JANUARY
20, 2021, THEY WERE LIKELY TO
LOSE THE HOUSE AND MAYBE THE
SENATE IN THIS MIDTERM ELECTION.
SO THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
SO IT'S NOT THE END OF THE
WORLD.
IT'S NOT THE END OF DEMOCRACY.
IT'S KIND OF PREPOSTEROUS AND
INSULTING.
>> Jesse: REJECT YOUR PARTY'S
MIDTERM MESSAGE.
YOU HAVE 20 SECONDS, GO!
>> Jessica: I HAPPENED TO BE
PARTICULARLY 1930'S SENSITIVE
SINCE MY FAMILY ACTUALLY DID
FLEE HITLER AND IT WAS KIND OF A
BIG DEAL.
AND I DON'T LIKE THOSE
COMPARISONS.
K.K.K. OUT, DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT, HITLER, DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
DENOMINATIONS OF FASCISM, IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT FRANKLY FROM
THE OTHER SIDE, DENOMINATIONS OF
SOCIALISM.
I KNOW HAROLD BROUGHT UP THIS
POINT YESTERDAY.
THE RIGHT OFTEN FLINGS AT THE
LEFT AND SAYS IF THEY GET INTO
POWER, IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE
VENEZUELA.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE EATING DOGS,
RIGHT?
AND ALL YOU'LL HAVE IS -->>
Jesse: CHEF BOYARDEE.
>> Jessica: THAT'S BETTER THAN
DOG.
>> Jesse: IS IT?
>> Jessica: THAT'S MY MIDTERM
MESSAGE.
>> Jesse: NOT EATING DOG FOOD!
>> Jessica: IT'S VERY SAD THAT
EVERYONE HAS BECOME SO IMMUNE TO
THE HORRIFIC THINGS THAT THE
OTHER SIDE IS SAYING TO THEM.
AND I HAPPENED TO THINK THAT
THERE ARE REALLY SERIOUS
REPUBLICAN THREATS TO DEMOCRACY
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE SAID
I WOULD NOT HAVE CERTIFIED THE
ELECTION.
I WAS TALKING TO SOMEONE IN NEW
YORK WHO IS GOING TO VOTE
TOMORROW, A DEMOCRAT, WHO IS
THINKING ABOUT LEE ZELDIN AND
SHE SAID MAKE YOUR CASE.
AND I TALKED ABOUT WHY I VOTED
FOR HER AND WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HAVE DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE.
AND HE SAID BESIDES -- HE CAME
OUT WITH AN AD ABOUT ABORTION
WHICH I THINK WAS SMART OF HIM
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE LAWS
AREN'T GOING TO CHANGE.
I SAID I COULD NOT VOTE FOR
SOMEONE WHO VOTED AGAINST
CERTIFYING A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
PERIOD, END OF STORY FOR ME.
AND I THINK PEOPLE LIKE DOUG
MASTORONI AND OTHERS ARE
DANGEROUS.
GOING TO THE EXTREMES IN
EVERYTHING TURNS EVERYBODY OFF
AND THEY GO INTO THAT BOOTH AND
THEY DO SOMETHING AND THEY DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO RESPOND TO
POLLS.
REPUBLICANS 28 POINTS LESS
LIKELY THAN DEMOCRATS TO TELL
POLLSTERS WHAT THEY WERE GOING
TO DO ON ELECTION DAY.
AND TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
LOWERING THE TEMPERATURE.
THIS IS ONE WAY THAT WE CAN DO
IT WHERE AT LEAST VOTERS WILL
FEEL LIKE YOU'VE HEARD THEM SAY
TALK TO ME ABOUT STUFF I
ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT AND THAT CAN
BE TALKING ABOUT JANUARY 6TH IN
A NORMAL WAY OR IT CAN BE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT MEDICARE FOR
ALL WOULD MEAN IN A NORMAL WAY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHO ELSE SAID
THAT, JESSICA?
STALIN.
>> Jessica: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Greg: CHECK IT.
>> Jessica: I WILL DURING THE
BREAK.
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
>> Jeanine: THEY SAY DEMOCRACY
WILL DIE IF THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
WIN TOMORROW.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANT IS ONE
PARTY RULE.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANT IS FOR
REPUBLICANS TO NEVER WIN AGAIN.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANT IS TO
DESPISE THE 74 MILLION AMERICANS
WHO VOTED MAGA OR VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HATE OTHER AMERICANS THAT
LIVE WITH THEM IN THE SAME
COUNTRY.
MY BELIEF IS THIS.
IF REPUBLICANS DON'T WIN, LAW
AND ORDER WILL CONTINUE TO BE
OUT OF CONTROL BECAUSE OF THE
DEMOCRAT POLICIES THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING ESPECIALLY IN NEW
YORK STATE.
IF THE REPUBLICANS DON'T WIN, IT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE END OF
FREE SPEECH AS WE SAW WITH BIG
TECH AND THE ELECTION IN 2020
WHEN THEY WOULDN'T ALLOW US TO
EVEN TALK ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN.
IF THE REPUBLICANS DON'T WIN,
THEN IT WILL BE A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY BECAUSE IT WILL BE THE
END OF EDUCATION WHERE TEACHERS
BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT IT WITHOUT US KNOWING
ABOUT IT.
FINALLY, THEY WANT ONE PARTY
RULE WHICH IS EVIDENCED BY THEIR
REPEATED DEGRADATION OF ANYBODY
THAT'S NOT A DEMOCRAT.
THAT'S WHAT'S AT STAKE.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR ONE PARTY
RULE.
>> Jessica: WHAT DEMOCRAT DO YOU
WANT IN CHARGE?
TELL ME!
WHAT DEMOCRAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> Jeanine: LET ME FINISH.
JOE BIDEN IS THE PRESIDENT.
SO THAT'S NOT ONE PARTY RULE.
>> Jessica: WOULD YOU LIKE HIM
TO WIN?
>> Jeanine: I DON'T WANT TO GO
THROUGH THIS.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO IS A DEMOCRAT.
AND MOST AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT
THE POWERS SHOULD BE SPLIT
BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANT IS THEY
WANT A DEMOCRAT HOUSE, SENATE
AND OVAL.
AND THAT'S BROUGHT US NOTHING
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT DEMOCRAT
I LIKE?
YOU, JESSICA.
>> Jessica: WH